nous sommes aujourd'hui en indre et
loire après plus de trente ans passés à
chartres en eure et loir patrick lepage
est venu s'installer à amboise puis ici
à charge et il y a 6 ans il a investi ce
site troglodytique que vous voyez
derrière moi pour en faire son atelier
de souffleur de verre
depuis c'est son élève qui a pris la
relève un artisanat qui est née il ya
plus de 2000 ans avec la création de la
can a soufflé une découverte de ce
métier je vous propose de suivre avec
charles mercier samuel foucault et
marion dubois
c'est dans ces caves taillé dans la
roche que pierre travaille son atelier
c'est aussi son terrain de jeu c'est là
où j'ai passé mes journées à fabriquer
les pièces a créé à attenter à faire
aussi des réparations les différentes
pièces
depuis vingt ans ils fabriquent façonne
et modèle des pièces de verre unique
comme il ya plus de 2000 ans la base
porté à 1500 degrés le sable se
liquéfiant se transforme alors en verre
mais avant de lui donner une forme il
faut coloré la pièce
mettre un morceau de couleur qu'on
appelle de la belote au bout de ma canne
je vais le faire fondre et ça me
permettra au moment de couper ma pièce
de colorer la bulle
j'ai mon père va colorer la pièce
entièrement de patrons uniforme couleur
ici tout est fait à l'ancienne pas de
machines seulement trois fours un peu
d'eau et quelques outils traditionnels
beaucoup de la forme condamné au pénal à
la main en seulement protège ce que fait
très chaud on va donner beaucoup la
porte avec du journal pour protéger la
main mais après avoir il ya quelques
outils pour faire des détails
il ya quand même degré là tout de suite
aux dents autour des 900 avant de
maîtriser l'art du soufflage de verre
pierre a connu des échecs mais a su
faire preuve de ténacité
on va mal de temps et ça fait pas partie
des choses qu'on apprend même aller à
l'école c'est des choses qu'on apprend
sur le tas fois au contact d'autres
d'autres tout fleurs soit dans
entraînant seul mais on vend beaucoup
d'erreurs c'est quoi les qualités
primordiales
pour être un bon souple heures sa
persévérance c'est la dernière étape la
mise au four pour éviter qu'un qui est
un choc thermique extinction ferchaud pc
ça alors c'est par choix mais parce que
le fourn et 4 500 degrés par rapport aux
autres mais ça permet d'éviter les chocs
thermiques un patrimoine que pierre
tente de transmettre aux curieux afin de
ne pas perdre cette tradition et ce
savoir faire
il fait partie des trois souffleur de
verre de la région d'être le rabattre un
petit peu ou tourner tout de suite ouais
c'est plus dans leur langue de la
découverte que les personnes voient un
peu comme en la matière réagi qu'ils
ressentent la chaleur qu'elle retrouve
pas quel but est aussi ça refroidit ce
que j'espère c'est que je vais tout
faire fondre et donner la forme de boule
ensuite vous recherchez l'hiver lui
donne une forme de boulet ont aplati les
visites et les initiations sont
possibles tout l'été à la verrerie d'art
de charger
et je suis avec annie duval la gérante
de la verrerie d'art d'amboise alors on
l'a vu dans sujet avec pierre votre
souffleur souffleur de verre
c'est quelque chose qui est important
pour vous c'est la transmission du
savoir
c'est la transmission du savoir de ce
qui a été acquis par nos souffleur et
qui va continuer à exister à l'infini on
espère surtout ne pas perdre mais c'est
ça ça fait plus de trente ans vous que
vous fait perdurer cette tradition et
c'est savoir artisanat été pendant vingt
ans avec la truck lepage et puis pierre
maintenant a pris la relève et on espère
que ça continue un du libre et la chance
ici c'est qu'on a des ateliers
d'initiation pour les passionnés du
verre ceux qui veulent découvrir la
matière avant tout contact
et puis voir un peu leurs yeux
émerveillés de partir d'une matière
liquide et à la réalisation d'un objet
c'est super et c'est vrai que la plupart
son je pense très content d'avoir eu ce
contact avec avec le vert et d'avoir
créé leur caisse de tous âges on peut
venir d'un calage à partir du moment où
on est motivé et je crois que la plus
jeune petite fille qu'on élude va avoir
7 ans et qu'ils étaient prêts motivés
donc pas de soucis et toutes les pièces
qui sortent ici sont des pièces uniques
c'est ça la particularité aussi oui
alors souffleur de verre ou dans notre
atelier nous n'avons que des pièces
uniques
il n'y a aucun moule donc il peut y
avoir des pièces qui vont se ressembler
mais chaque pièce est fait avec les
mains et ses pièces uniques ou est-ce
qu'on peut les admirer ici dans la
région alors essentiellement derrière la
porte
ici dans notre galerie et puis dans
quelques endroits où on présente des
produits de métiers d'art notamment on
participe au salon les métiers de l'art
justement d'orléans et puis quelques
lieux
nous présentons nos créanciers très bien
merci beaucoup et quant à nous on se
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle visite
du patrimoine industriel de la région
centre val de loire